uh New Orleans the grace it's one of my
favorite places I've ever visited I love
it there
um what area are you from
um downtown okay I have a project design
project
so I went to uh
where do we go eat hot wings no there
was a hot wing place that the dude from
do you remember the group juvenile was
in UTP
skip he owned a hot wing place what that
is man
chicken watermelon oh you want the
chicken and water yes and it was so good
they had a they had a dream they had a
bunch of drinks named after famous
people they had like Obama juice and
Oprah juice well no I ain't gonna lie
taking the watermelon some of the best
wings in the city bro some of the best
wings I've ever had mine them crazy yeah
you got me one too that [__] was so good
damn bro yeah and I remember just going
in there like oh yeah the dude from UTP
was this place I was like what what's
the spice to eat out too
I don't know
honestly bro if I'm gonna be honest out
here like LA's food situation is
probably a little overrated I'm gonna go
to boy Boiling Crab boy
I want the bull I think that's what it's
called or they have the bag of seafood
no not boil boil boa like some [__] like
that oh boa this the steakhouse yeah
yeah I mean it's a steakhouse but they
had a crab they had a crab that was cut
on both sides so all you gotta do is
this to the crab fall right now well
that's the best [__] man this is so good
they used to do a brunch out here at the
Four Seasons I don't know if they still
do it but it's like 150 a person yeah
you go in and they have king crab legs
already open for you cause I love crabs
man I need to be the hardest [__] though
is open in the [__] crab bruh I ain't
never used to like opening crabs I ain't
never used to like even having crabs
because I ain't know how to open them
and then you'll cut yourself open them
some pain in the ass when I learned how
to do it do it that's all I want to eat
yeah crabs are amazing I mean [__] y'all
be eating all the [__] crawfish and
[__] out there in New Orleans damn you
got me on cuff isn't that I can't do the
Crawfish it's something about the eyes I
can't do it I can do all the other
shellfish in the world it's crazy bro
like that's the best [__] that [__]
better than crab that [__] everything
really I swear I've never sees it from
New Orleans I've never tried it
everywhere else is trash everywhere in
this world trade I had the um what's
y'all type of sandwiches the po boys I
had those from work well you know what
I've been in New Orleans twice we went
to jeans jeans I don't even know bro you
didn't go to jeans you didn't really do
nothing man they set jeans down the rest
of people I went to some spot um in the
French Quarter for sure nah yeah nah you
probably went to Acme or something I
don't know I know that there was like a
place with green grenade drinks oh you
went to the hand grenade please yeah and
um that was the first time I had ever
seen a car on like 32-inch rims
yeah we don't be doing it out there but
no I saw it in New Orleans it was a
[__] no usually ran into somebody
that's the whole frame of the card
if it's on oh yeah I seen a couple dudes
do that like I just seen one dude do
that man I got this man cut the we hit
every bump we hit it felt like we hit a
speed book right because like there's no
way that's just not practical no you
can't yes if something else was like
there's dunks and then there's whatever
that is that's something else uh but
it's crazy because you uh
being one of the first guys since Wayne
to really put on nationally out of New
Orleans not to say that there aren't
other artists by the way shout out to
currency who's [__] a legend and
mercy was in an error window yeah but
he's got a new album out with uh JD
that's coming soon so I'm gonna shout
out to spitter but you had [__]
Birdman
pass you the Baton on the intro your
album man that's crazy huh I ain't even
realize how crazy that was until like
two months ago [__] told me that I'm
like you have [__] Birdman passing
you the [__] torch officially on
record
that shit's crazy
how did you like how does that happen
like like
um I don't know I just asked him to send
me some [__] was in the studio and he
said he like that's what I want
you know kick the album off that's what
I want
and he was like I want to do this for
you yeah he just he told me the other
day like I won't be on everything you
ever released like
Birdman was one of the first people
believed in me though like two months
and three months until rapping he called
me like you the one like he didn't try
signing you yeah he tried to sign he was
the first person trying to sign me it
just didn't work out
well
like him I always two months to write
but I ain't released number one tape
like I got released I I got I got signed
at the three tapes the tape that I had
was called I quit because I was about to
stop rapping okay and the day I got my
cover for a birdman called me like man I
won't sign you [__] me up you flew me to
Cali we just lost touch in like the next
week or some [__] like that I had wind
up doing say cheese I ain't even know
who said cheese but then Sean brought me
to the league when Capital One to sign
me and then I was going back and forth
to live with them so then like [__] yeah
what made you eventually like for you
because I'm sure it's got to be kind of
cool to be courted like that it almost
probably feels like similar to like a
NBA free agent feels like when they're
trying to sign to you know a team like
how cool was that just having like a
little bidding work going for you uh
I don't know I'm ready for the next one
you know I'm gonna fulfill this deal and
then we go double back I had like ten
thousand followers and like
so they my labor called me before
anything like you know what I'm saying
so they kind of they they got they
looked up like you know what I'm saying
they got in early yeah they got in there
at least they believed in you earlier
they believed the mirror that's why
that's why I ain't gonna lie like
that's why with this live I'm at right
now like I don't know anyone lead them
because they believed in me like that
that means a lot no for sure for sure
man